we got some new merch made but it's only
exclusive for our petrie honors
so if you go on our patreon we got some
new tiers we got the coffee mug tear
and the hoodie tier and if you're
defibrillator you get
both so make sure you go to patreon
check that out and thank you guys so
much for supporting and enjoy the video
[Music]
what is everyone's dream car in here
aston martin vanquish
good one i like it james bond inspired
huh it's not even because of bond but
that car is beautiful
it is a beautiful car very beautiful i
want a soda can with four donuts as
wheels
very very very yeah out of this world
so when you park somewhere and you're at
a meeting for two hours you come back
and your dorms are eating you're like
[ __ ] i come out to a bunch of people
from the show biggest loser just eating
yeah yeah yeah sounds about right you
just eat your own car
we're gonna let innocent people [ __ ]
make this joke get out i visualize all
of it no because i'm gonna
be working entertainment so who but them
it's not the model
i picture jillian michael's yelling at
people eating eating his donut tires
oh god you guys have a dream car 67
chevelle it's my dream well that is your
that's been consistent
you can buy it now why don't you just
get it
you got all these other dream cars
before your dream car want to move to
vegas first we have to [ __ ] drive it
there
oh true true you want to put the miles
on something like that
okay i taught you how to buy it i was a
a tax-free but you know you don't even
want to do it that way
i do i do i got a buddy who [ __ ]
bought a delorean as a tax write-off
you can i'll tell you how i'll tell you
how off-camera give it a secret
yes for patreon oh a patreon
what's your dream car i don't think i
care enough about cars to have a dream
car
are you driving it already uh i'm a big
tesla fan
like it's going to be hard somebody so
mine's elise oh right you have one yeah
oh yeah
you have a tesla too we're both teslas
no which one do you have okay
hers is next but it's wrapped [ __ ] so
deal with that
it's like a rainbow i love it i love it
yes it'll be hard for me like so when my
lease is up next year i'm gonna be like
[ __ ] i might want to just keep it her
car's got gay pride
in certain lighting conditions right
right the lights gotta hit it right it
doesn't even care about the gate cause
at all
it's a more copper thing it depends on
the way where the light hits it it's
like an oil spill it could be rainbow
it could be gold you don't know oil
spill is a great way to
uh to describe like frying on a frying
pan what's yours
uh not a mercedes amg g63
i don't even know what that is no it's a
all right wait do you have a dream car
case
uh i would probably go with uh aston
martin of some sort probably an
old school one very classy very james
bond inspired
are you talking about the gold
what the [ __ ] is it i didn't pull a
photo there i do
love cars from movies though like you
know the uh eleanor from gone in 60
seconds that one's nice i love that much
is that 66
65 60 something mustang i want a 65
cadillac deville
what's that one i can't picture it even
like a boat is it pretty big
cadillac's yeah they were big boys big
ones dude my grandfather
drove a lincoln that's big too yeah and
they were [ __ ]
he's ready for war basically if you
crash into his car
he doesn't even know he hit you yeah did
you know a lincoln was a
luxury vehicle yeah my grandpa would not
talk about it because when i was um when
i finally got a little money i decided
to rent a luxury vehicle
and i and a lincoln pulled up and i said
what the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] is this you're like this is
your luxury vehicle sir
and i'm like god dang it they're coming
back lincoln navigator is the nicest suv
oh my goodness i would love to get a
lincoln navigator because of mcconaughey
bro
yes he went fishing ice fishing with it
how crazy is it that when my grandfather
died mcconaughey was like
the biggest [ __ ] ever and now
mcconaughey is like what men look up to
they've been looking up to him no but my
grandpa no no
you have to remember the mcconausons
happened like 2009
like 2011. that he did he did mud and he
became like everyone's hero
no so yeah so before that he did this
jennifer lopez movie where everyone
[ __ ] hated it girls wanted to [ __ ]
no
no well okay the girls were in the
[ __ ] women worshipped him but then
then
it was called failure to launch nobody
watched the movie i saw it
with katie came here but yeah continue
and everyone's like [ __ ] this movie
[ __ ] mcconaughey he's truly hit a career
low but then he had a mcconaissance
where he ended up winning
oscar within three years of that wow and
now guys look up to him
yeah but jill guys don't want to be the
guy that girls want to [ __ ]
okay no they really don't wait why so
like in high school like all the girls
want to [ __ ] like justin timberlake or
like nsync or like johnny depp like guys
don't want to be
the pussiest dudes in the world but it
sounds like you probably never got laid
yeah it sounds like it comes out of
jealousy sounds like you're an intel bro
no you want to be the guy that gets laid
but you don't want to look like that guy
you want to be the undertaker
nobody wants to [ __ ] that i know but
guys think that's what
like the epitome of maleness is the
[ __ ] undertaker
it's just youtube no no no i think it's
pretty common
no sure okay anyways
back to cars uh so
uh mercedes so a russian vlogger
has a i think this is actually the wrong
mod i think they wrote the wrong name in
the
article is it a concept car no the
mercedes amg g63
it might be a different country has
different models maybe that's what it
was because i looked it up and it gave
me the the wagon
the the g could be but it's not the g
class in what i'm talking about so the
article
rider didn't even know the car
some really fancy mercedes car yes and
we'll just go with that
some really fancy mercedes car uh a
russian vlogger has
and he's been very disgruntled with
mercedes in particular because
of uh the car one breaks down all the
time
it sounds like the g wagon dude that's
what i hear about the g wagons actually
yeah
so super nice super luxury but in terms
of endurance i mean
not endurance durability not so good oh
buddy it's crazy because that that looks
like a military car
i love it i love the way i love you
buddy i hate to break this to you but
when we get our ass to martin they're
going to break down a lot
absolutely you know that right we'll
just drive it on sundays i mean we're
going to be so rich that
doesn't matter [ __ ] it leave it on the
side of the road my sunday car [ __ ]
yeah i'm not gonna it's not a daily
driver if i ever get my dream car
so i mean and i don't know if this guy's
using this car as a daily driver but it
sounds like it because he's very
disgruntled with the fact that it's
constantly in the in the shop and one
time he
even uh took his car to a friend's
garage to get it fixed up and realized
that the dealership lied to him about
some parts that he bought
and it wasn't actually like the
expensive things that he was supposed to
get
and it was some cheap [ __ ] and so now in
complete total retaliation against
mercedes
he has decided to do
this and if you like fancy nice
this cars trigger warning for you if you
love fancy nice cars that's a beautiful
car though it is beautiful
wow that's cool looking
oh
about the group i can't wait i can't
wait no not the grass
he did it he's like i don't know what if
he turns on fire dude
dude by the way that looks like that
even is it does it even work that way
he's like i'm doing this on swamp lands
oh it does work
of course he's going to put russian
music in his uh little video here
i love the way michael bay does it where
the car bounces
oh
[Music]
wow yeah so he went viral for this
what's the littering laws like out there
pull that up i don't even care if that
car sucks ass it was really sexy though
i just don't like things the burning of
the car is sexy are the car this car
itself was very sexy already
very clean lines very nice nice paint
job yeah good
body i liked it mm-hmm
i like it i like watching cars like that
like it's like a movie
mm-hmm true yeah
what country is this in russia yeah so i
guess they don't really have i mean i
don't know if you
can you do this in the states and if
they if you make a video and they know
it's you that burnt a car and just left
it there
you have to do it in a baker's field you
can't leave it there you can't leave it
there right so my buddy richard brian he
does a bunch of videos like this
and he he like [ __ ] slow-mo shoots
cars and all kind of blows them up and
[ __ ] and uses [ __ ] gallon guns and
[ __ ]
he does this channel uh called full mag
where he just blows the [ __ ] out of
everything he basically does it in the
desert
because in the desert there are no laws
basically it sounds funny he just leaves
it there
no no he has to clean it all up oh
that's nice he sends it to russia
yeah he donates it to russia
but yeah like um what do you guys think
agree
or disagree with disagreement we're
definitely going to say 170
000 cards definitely disagree mercedes
got their money
what are they going to shed a tear like
oh no his protest
it's like you already paid [ __ ] this
is your [ __ ] they don't give a [ __ ]
about you it just feels so wasteful
it doesn't make me not want to buy the
car i want to buy the car more now right
it looks cool the way that they filmed
it oh yeah it's like
[ __ ] yeah it feels like the car is
available for a limited time only now
or else it's going to blow up true it's
a great ad yeah what's up
mercedes should be taking no it's a
marketing team like burning the [ __ ]
car down yes
now it looks like there's one less car
so it's more scarce
i'm so sick of seeing cars driving the
same surfaces the same like oh road with
a little bit of water like all this [ __ ]
and like car commercials all the same
this is a better car yeah they're
driving
by the cliffs and it's all windy and
[ __ ] i'm tired of it it's boring
if it survived the fire though if it
survived the fire that would have been
yeah he drives off in the car
i didn't quite see that but that's
probably what's gonna happen or if it's
a ford commercial it's got like fake
tough guy dennis leary
wait what was the guy hey it's a [ __ ]
ford okay what do you want okay
i don't know i i've been on the
workforce for like [ __ ] 45 years but
like i'm a pretty tough guy
no who's the guy that the [ __ ] the
movie with uh
he's like he activates the bombs but
then now he became a singer like he has
a single out what
wait what wait wait actually oh jeremy
renner yes
oh jeremy renner has a singer yes
he the who makes this oh he does have a
scene right jeremy renner the avenger
the yeah he has the
other song crystalia makes fun of it all
of that i mean before he got cancelled
i think it's an edm song too what i
cannot imagine jeremy renner doing music
music
it has like this crazy sounding intro
and crystal used to make fun of like wow
and that would go perfect with the
this commercial we're producing here i'm
playing an ad right now
but yes see this is him main attraction
is the song
i'm not going to play the audio i'll
show you the music video let's see
jeremy renner in
music video form or how about we mute it
for them but we
yeah is he dressed like hawkeye because
it's the end we'll play we'll play the
song
it'll get less views it's good this is
this is jeremy renner the avenger
oh he's maybe go in the middle
there oh it's gotta have a dope can we
can we just mute it yeah yeah yeah yeah
the intro
wait what is it you want to hear it or
yeah yeah
and that's it for that i'm not doing no
content id here that's called auto-tune
and
but you guys can go check it out and you
look here yeah so that would this would
go perfect
with the commercial which is burning
mercedes oh
well here i mean it's time it's time for
us to go anyway thank you for watching
you